this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice dr john
deloney ramsey personality best-selling
author
and host of an explodingly popular
podcast i got to come up with a better
phrase than that but
but it is healthy explodingly is
explodingly popular
it's uh it's it's yeah there's a lot
well anyway but dave you've been with us
for 30 years
there's a lot of people listening to it
in a very short period of time and
i i'm proud of it and i uh
i'm proud of you and i love that it's
popular because what you're putting out
there the material
the answers to questions in people's
lives is absolutely valuable
and it is uh it's unique and it's fresh
and refreshing and so i'm glad that i'm
glad the curve
on the listenership is through the roof
well i appreciate that plus i just like
being associated with a big hit
well and i think 30 years you've been
making up words so why start now stop
now right
we're going to go with exploding this
isn't the season to fix your grammar
dave so i
say explodingly let's do it man i mean
it's uh it's a little late in life
because um number one i'm beyond help
number two i just really don't care
that's right that's the the du
that one does it right there so open
phones if you want to talk to this
couple of clowns open triple eight
eight two five five two two five we'll
talk about your life
and your money uh the call is free and
some say the advice is worth exactly
what you pay for it laura is with us in
los angeles hey laura
welcome to the ramsey show hi thank you
for taking my call
sure what's up um i'm a little nervous
i'm going to try to calm down you'll be
fine we've never lost a patient you'll
make it
okay my husband and i are at um total
odds kind of right now what to do about
a decision and so
um we're calling you so we're new
listeners we've only been listening for
a couple months but we've listened a lot
and so basically we're 50 and 60 years
old
all of our money is in uh real estate
we've done well in real estate we have
about six thousand six million dollars
in a
paid off real estate it's all rentals i
hate it when that happens
and we probably made some stupid
decisions but we were lucky and it
worked out
i think you've made some good decisions
somewhere
okay so anyway where we're at right now
is
everything is owned outright except for
our personal residence
and a vacation home in palm springs
that's very successful airbnb
um our personal residence is worth like
1.6 million and we owe
350 000 on it and our rental home is
worth about a million
and we also owe 350 000 on it my husband
wants us to sell
a paid off rental that's about
worth about 350 000. they'll be on free
and clear it brings in about 2
000 a month and it's really it's a condo
it's easy it's
you know it's just the money just comes
in he wants to sell that
to pay off our palm springs airbnb
just so he just feels like 260. now he
just wants to not have that debt you
know he wants to just have a home
mortgage and he wants to really attack
the home mortgage
and this whole debt free idea is brand
new to us you know so
um and i want to keep it because we have
no
retirement other than renters we have no
stocks we have no i have six million
dollars in real estate
we do no longer a month
no whining allowed this condo is not
going to break your retirement bank
right sorry uh i mean it's okay
why so why did he pick that condo to
sell out of all the other properties
um he wants to sell something and i
think he well also the
our tenant just moved out because vacant
which california rent laws would make it
easier
you know to sell a vacant unit and so
it's just sitting there and rented you
know it's just
and we're at a stalemate like kind of
locking the heads and i said well why
don't we take
rent it take the 2000 and since we don't
need that to live on it just
attack the palm springs mortgage you
know and then we could just
and if they're already on 15-year fixed
that we're already
only 13 years old what is your household
income it's all off of rental properties
is your income
all off of rental basically yeah so what
did you take in in cash that you put in
your pocket that you paid taxes on last
year
200 000 on 6 million
well yeah well it was like 340 is what
it
brings in but then we have we write off
a lot yeah
i'm talking about not i'm not talking
about uh depreciation
but i mean you have actual expenses that
eat your cash
i would hope you're making 340 after
expenses on six million dollar portfolio
uh well maybe it's just because real
estate's so expensive like our home is
in that you know what i mean
cash you should have 340
000 income net of expenses before
depreciation
on six million dollar portfolio anyway
that's still low but
you ought to at least have that yeah
well we don't
you don't so what is the cash after
expenses before depreciation that you
guys have coming in to work with
i'm not sure okay well that'd be a good
number to have
okay because that's called your income
right that's what you have to work with
because if i wanted to answer the
question how fast can i pay off
700 000 worth of real estate debt
i would need to know what my income is
to do that with
i will tell you 24 000 on a property
that's worth 350
000 as your gross income meaning you're
netting
somewhere around 17 000 really sucks
the roi on that condo is pity full
yeah it's bad i don't care if it's low
if it's hassle
not much hassle you're not you know
you're not making a
you're making what four percent on your
money
that sucks so i thought i was hoping
maybe you're gonna tell me he picked it
out because the income is horrible on it
but um i know it's just that it's empty
yeah right now okay
yeah well i i'm as you know from
listening for just a few weeks i'm gonna
lead you to be debt-free as fast as i
can so the answer to your question
is gonna be you have to go back and do
some homework and you guys have to keep
talking
because you need to get to the bottom of
this so number one we need these
properties
to be producing and a cash on cash
rate of return that is substantial
okay number two once that's our income
once we know what our income is number
two
how fast if we keep the condo can we get
these seven hundred fifty thousand
dollars worth of debt cleared
how many years is that gonna take yeah
how many years is that to take five
years six years seven years he's 60
years old
he doesn't want to leave you with debt
and that's that's the goal okay he's
trying to take care of you
so uh then then uh if you if it's going
to take you
15 years because you're really making
200 000 on this 6 million because your
your real estate sucks um if that's
really all you're making on it
and it's going to take you 10 or 15
years to clear this yeah you need to
sell the condo
because you need to clear this debt as a
part of preparing
for him to not be there or if the golden
years whatever we want to call these
these next this next decade or two if
you're if however you're making three or
four hundred thousand dollars that you
have cash on
at your fingertips which i suspect you
should be it i mean unless these
properties are just not well run
uh you should be well yeah okay i feel
like because
everything's so expensive it's not
anything to do with it
right okay yeah if if a property is
worth
a million dollars it should rent for a
price
the rental price should reflect the
value of the property
right if you've raised the prices as the
values have gone up
because rents go up as values go up and
so
anyway i own several hundred thousand
dollars several hundred
million dollars of real estate i love
real estate so
it's my you're my sandbox right now
kiddo so you either need to clear the
debt with your income
or you need to clear the debt by selling
the condo in the next five years
now you run the numbers out and decide
which one's the best
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that
even in adversity that you have what it
takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance career training
and a paycheck to help you avoid debt no
matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
well speaking of real estate if you've
ever made a dumb decision with zeros on
the end you know you didn't do your
research
me too most people make choices based on
feelings or opinions especially when
buying a house
but when it comes to the real estate
market feelings aren't your friend
facts are well john says that about a
lot of things
so check your facts find out what you
can actually afford
research what's trending in home prices
talk to a
reputable real estate agent in your area
never buy a house again without fax
text the word house to 33
789 to get an agent who will help you
make smart decisions
text house two three three
seven eight nine sarah is
with us in dallas texas hi sarah welcome
to the ramsey show
hello thank you so much for having me
sure how can i help
all right well um my husband and i are
in baby step two and uh since december
of 2019 we've paid off 58 thousand
dollars
all right and that we only have about
three here we're very proud of that but
uh we are on the second half of our debt
now and that's 37 000 left
in student loans um but due to increased
costs of having a second child over last
year
and taking a job with a decreased salary
our shovel is substantially smaller
compared to what it used to be
so i'm trying to think of ways
brainstorm ways to be gazelle intense
in a new situation and i had this crazy
idea
and my husband was not super thrilled
with it and actually asked me
if i could call you to talk about it
what if we paid off
our paid or what if we sold our paid off
cars
if we did that it would be a big step
but it would wipe out this 37k
immediately and we could then focus
on all of the other things that we need
to do and then you have a forty thousand
dollars
back into a car we have two twenty three
thousand dollar cars
oh you'd sell both your cars yes that's
why it's a big step
what would you and then you get your two
beaters huh
yes maybe not beaters and what is your
house what is your household income
140 000 a year
and why can you not pay off 37 making
140 000
um so we bring home 8 800 a month which
is a lot and we're very fortunate
um 5 thousand of it goes between daycare
and our mortgage they're about the same
that's over five thousand dollars
uh we spend a thousand on groceries
diapers household things
your daycare is 60 000 a year
uh yeah but well between the two kids uh
we pay
twenty two hundred dollars a month so
not fifty thousand a year
that's that's not five thousand oh five
mortgage plans
i'm sorry it's between day care and
mortgage oh yeah
okay yeah 140
i don't know why mortgage and daycare
are on the same list but anyway we'll
put them there
so 140 minus 60 isn't that isn't that
80.
140 minus 60 is 80. why can you not pay
off thirty seven thousand dollars again
so i can pay off thirty seven thousand
dollars i have a thousand
based on our no our debt snowball i have
a thousand dollars a month going towards
that
i don't think your budget is very
sacrificial
and that's true there are other things
that we could we could yeah like you're
still doing a whole bunch of crap that
you don't need to be doing
okay well then we'll take a look at that
and make it a little bit i mean
help me with this because i'm not just
making this up i mean i just took 140
and i took out the mortgage and i took
out the daycare which were your two
primary things you're worried about you
don't have any payments
except except a student loan payment and
we took care of daycare and we took care
of the mortgage now we got to buy lights
water and food
and you can't find 37 thousand dollars
that's just weird um okay well looking
looking at our budget and the growth
that we come home with like i said it's
800
yeah that's 120 000. that's 120
absolutely
minus well and that's our growth right
that's what we take home after taxes our
net i'm sorry
um and then we take uh and then it's
about a thousand dollars on
food diapers other household items
a thousand on student loans about seven
hundred dollars in bills
and at the end of the month we may have
an extra five hundred dollars left which
will go towards
um towards our specificity you did not
get down to five hundred dollars
your budgets you're still not doing it
i'm sorry i'm the only thing i'm good at
is math
and you still did not spend all that
money so you've got some work to do
kiddo
sharpen z pencil sharpen the pencil
uh so one car maybe but i don't think so
you're putting a thousand dollars a
month towards
37 that's 12 of the 37. so all you need
is 24 000
all you got to do is find 24 000 out of
140 120 take home pay
for one year and to do it in one year
then if you wanna do it in two years
all you need is twelve thousand dollars
i'll do it in one year just get it done
with it i i really think you can do it i
really think that there's some i i i
think there's some whining in this
budget
i really do yeah it does it sounds like
i want to be comfortable
let me tell you i'll go further i don't
think you're doing the whole budget
because you're you're doing this from
your head that's why you've got daycare
and diapers broken out of separate line
items
they're you know diapers don't go in a
separate line item they're not that big
a line item
you're you're trying to crack crank this
through in your brain you need to sit
down and do a
written detailed line by line budget
with every dollar
every dot get on the every dollar app
with your husband the two of you give
every dollar
a name and you're gonna see where why
i'm why i'm raising up on you
you're gonna see there's money left here
and you can knock this out no you don't
need to sell your cars you need to
tighten your budget and lower your
stinking lifestyle
and i actually think that when she first
called dave i was gonna say yeah sell
your cars and be done with this thing
but i think the i think the
exercise oh it's right it's much better
than selling the cars yeah
this is gonna be a al i hate to use this
where's me a spiritual exercise for his
crew to get down and
and see what you're made of yeah yeah
this is going to force you to do the
last 10 percent of truth
yes which is the hardest is the detailed
budget
because you can i mean you can do big
piece budgets in your head
and when you make 140 grand you just
feel like you got so much wiggle room
right and you should have and it's
frustrating when you get to the end of
the month and there's no money
money left but you haven't detailed it
out i'm
i might be wrong but i'm not i might be
wrong but i'm not
been doing this too long so that that's
my opinion you keep digging on it kiddo
if we can help you we're here to help
you but
part of the time we help you by um by
raising up on you because we love you we
want you to win
all right up next is going to be armin
armin's in los angeles hey armin how are
you
good how are you guys better than i
deserve what's up
all right so before i get into my
question i just want to give some
context on my situation right now so
i'm 17 years old i'm on my last semester
at a
community college and i'm about to
transfer to a uc school
but i'm faced with two different um
conflicting opinions so
i'm faced with the dilemma where if i
transfer to uc irvine
i would need to rent out a private house
through uc irvine housing
and on the other hand if i go to ucla
i'll need to get a car
um but it's that question of should i
lease or should i buy
because my surroundings of family and
friends are
they're they're both raising pretty good
arguments for leasing and buying so i i
don't know
what a car
oh okay well the only people that
promote leasing a car are broke people
okay i mean the wealthy people don't
lose cars
i mean a few of them do but by and large
let me tell you we did a study of 10
000 millionaires the largest study of
millionaires ever done
none of them not a single one of the 10
000 said
you know i became a millionaire because
i i really leveraged
the use of that car by borrowing on it
not one i mean it wasn't a small
percentage
it was freaking zero armin now this is
not your broke friend or family member
who can make an intellectual argument
this are real millionaires they don't
borrow money on cars dude
and when you ask them what the largest
mistake they ever made in their working
lifetime they usually say
i borrowed to buy brand new cars i
bought a new car i bought a brand new
car when i was 26 and i was so stupid
when i was 26
and now i'm 46 and i'm i would have been
a millionaire four years sooner if i
hadn't bought that stupid buck car
on payments that i couldn't afford to
buy so to answer your question norman i
drove a 1988 20 tercel easy hatchback it
cost a thousand bucks i bought it from
some lady at my church whose husband had
passed away
and that got me through my undergraduate
it got me through my first year of my
professional job
and that's still driving somewhere right
yep buy
the cheapest beater car you can get to
get to and from you're a
18 year old kid don't take financial
advice from broke people son
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
sean and char are in denver and it says
on my screen
that you guys are debt free
congratulations
thank you how much have you paid off
we paid off a hundred thousand dollars
in
27 months wow good for you and your
range of income during that time
is actually pretty steady we are about a
hundred thousand dollars a year
okay so kind of like the lady i was
talking to a minute ago making 140 to
pay off 37 they paid off 127 months
making 100.
exactly so i have to hear the story now
because it seems like maybe i know what
i'm doing okay
so allegedly what kind of debt was the
hundred thousand
our debt was um the irs heloc
like credit cards auto and medical bills
wow i mean you had so you had some nasty
piranha in that pond
yes yeah the tax man was uh not real
happy with us
yeah how much of the 100k was was was
the kgb i mean the irs
it was about 20 000 was to the irs how
did you end up owing that much in taxes
uh well i i went a few years without
uh filing
[Laughter]
i'm gonna go with the my bad on that one
yeah yeah i'm just thinking that
yeah i got it oops yeah so uh what
happened
27 months ago what was your wake-up call
two and a half years ago
uh well so sharon and i have both
been through one marriage already so
when we met
we decided that we were gonna base our
relationship
in uh god's word and uh try and live
our relationship by his will and uh as
as we were moving through and we decided
to get married and
we were planning our wedding we were
kind of noticing how much it was going
to cost us
and uh you know as part of being
living in god's will was to be good
stewards of his blessings
so you know and uh being one of the
blessings that he's given us is
you know our financial uh money and
how much we make and you know so we're
were talking about it and decided that
you know we wanted to cash roll our
our wedding and we wanted to get out of
debt and
you know start our our life together on
on the right foot so that's kind of how
we
decided to do that and i'd heard of uh
you from years ago you're kind of a
household name around
our our family and um so we got your
book and
we were reading it to each other uh
before bed for battle
how romantic right yeah right well i
gotta admit
i put sure to sleep a couple times that
would be me
you were reading it but i would be the
one but that's great i love it
so a hundred thousand dollar income what
do you guys do for a living
um i um own my own hair salon
business in boulder colorado yeah
and i am uh i i design medical equipment
very good
okay so you've been married about uh two
and a half years three years
uh coming up on two years in may okay so
you started the process a little bit
before marriage then
yes okay excellent excellent well
congratulations
you guys who had the first conversation
with who actually sat down and said
hey what if we did this because i take
that first conversation especially for a
new couple
takes a lot of courage a lot of
vulnerability who who's the first one to
have that conversation
that totally is on sean's shoulders
so he looked at his wife and his
soon-to-be wife and said
what if we just scaled back and cash
flowed this and
what if we stopped spending so much
money and you were all in
all in yeah oh that's cool yeah
so you were feeling the stress in the
pinch too then
well yeah we i mean i came into our
relationship with you know a good sixty
thousand dollars
of that hundred thousand dollars that we
had
and i just didn't you know when you have
that much debt you don't
i don't know like i didn't know where i
was going and i was living paycheck to
paycheck and i didn't want to be like
that that was
my typical my family's a typical
mo and that's i didn't want to do that i
wanted to change that
you just think that walking through life
with those ankle weights on and
not sleeping and not knowing how we're
gonna eat the last couple days that's
just normal right
yeah get used to it yeah yeah how's it
feel now that you're out
oh my gosh it's amazing uh and honestly
i
as soon as we started doing this and we
were knocking bills out left and right
that's when my
i started to feel like i was free
it was great you don't even have to be
there you just got to know that you can
get there
yeah yeah we saw it coming it was great
so what did you learn about yourself and
about each other through this 27 months
well we were we were just talking about
that this morning and
um you know one of the things that we
learned was
you know we we don't always speak the
same language when we're talking about
our finances and budget and you know
just life in general so
sitting down and forcing ourselves to
learn how the each other communicates
and you know how to
how to listen and speak each other's
language was
really nice and so give me an example of
when one of you was speaking french and
the other one speaking russian
um it you know it usually came up when
we were doing our budget
and char would be trying to make sense
of the
numbers in in her head and i'm trying to
make sense of the numbers in my head
and you know i'm looking at it as you
know an engineer and she's looking at it
as a
hair stylist so
those two things didn't always uh line
up okay so the nerd and the free spirit
for one thing right
yeah yeah absolutely or the spreadsheet
lover in the room the guy the guy
reading
a financial book to his his new wife in
bed and the artist
right and i'm falling asleep that's
right yeah i am the artist
right yeah yeah this is great i love it
guys you guys are amazing i'm so proud
of you very very well done what do you
tell people the key to getting out of
that is
um well i think that the key or
our secret anyways is that it has to be
uh you have to get over the heart
problem instead of it having a math
problem
so when you change your heart the math
will do itself
oh yeah profound very well done
good good job you guys well we've got a
copy of rachel cruz's latest
new york times bestseller know yourself
know your money and it'll help with the
russian and the french yes that's what
it's for what would you tell to a new
couple
who's about to get married or just got
married that
how this benefited you two because i
want you to give hope to folks who are
thinking
i'm not gonna have this conversation
it's definitely a hard conversation but
i think in the long run i mean it's
definitely well worth it i mean it's
just to have
the debt off of your shoulders and not
have to worry
about anything like when also the when
the pandemic hit
because of my career you know we were
closed for two months out here and we
didn't have to
it didn't hurt us as bad as most people
would because we were on a budget and
um we still live on a budget
even though we're debt-free yeah me too
i i just
i tell everybody that they should do it
whether you're married or you're single
because
just the financial freedom and that
weight lifted off of your shoulders is
huge i can't even explain it like and
i'll go one step deeper and suggest that
you all two have worked together on a
hard thing
they got behind the thing right you got
behind the
the fear and you guys worked through
something hard together and now you all
know
hand in hand y'all can conquer anything
it's not a matter of if but when life
throws its next thing at you y'all
two both know we can do this because
we've done yeah
we're gonna take over the world next
there you go man i love it man well it
needs a good taking over so would you
please
get in business hurry up sean hey pay
your taxes on the way too brother yeah
keep your taxes paid that way the world
won't kick back but yeah
i love it congratulations all right sean
and char
in denver colorado a hundred thousand
dollars paid off
as newlyweds in 27 months making a
hundred grand
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three two one where's it free
[Applause]
now let's just round that 27 months up
to 36 months and call 100 000
33 000 a year making a hundred thousand
i will say it for you america dave was
right
he's always right it's frustrating i sit
next to him and he signs my paychecks
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today julie is
in denver hey julie welcome to the
ramsey show how can we help
hi thank you for taking my call sure
what's up
um i have kind of a funny situation i
have a brother-in-law who just offered
to take us on a trip
uh this summer we're on baby step
two and this year already has uh
we've had some extra bills come up with
some medical
stuff we think it's strange that they've
offered to pay for a trip for us and we
don't know how to
say no we don't want to go because we
don't ever want to pay them
back even though it's a gift why is it
strange
well they have not talked to us for
about six years and then in the back
excuse me about a year ago they've had a
change of heart
and want to reconnect
that's nice yeah it's nice it's nice
it's your your husband's brother brother
yes
so is there something about this gift
you feel like is gonna have strings
attached to it
yes um there my husband
and his brother had a fight over a
four-wheeler
um about six years ago and it's just now
being repaired
whoa
like we're being invited back to family
gatherings
and stuff oh so you got ruled out of mom
and dad's and everybody's
yes but you know that was bigger than a
four-wheeler right
i think so yeah i have an in-laws a
thousand percent
bigger than a four-wheeler yeah that's
probably some 30-year-old stuff
that was proxy ward with the
four-wheeler i think so it was a joint
owned
you know father and son's four-wheeler
yeah
and it got ugly or you don't
ex-communicate family members
over a toy right there's usually other
stuff there
uh yeah there's big stuff but it's
strange you know just the other day they
offered to
bring us on this trip and we're on baby
step two
and we are just not there to go on
vacation but
it's strange we don't know how to answer
because if we say no it's a money thing
and then they say
we're paying for it how much of this is
um
your pride i don't
know well it would be kind of hard to be
like thanks for the
airfare and hotel and why is that hard
i just don't want it to blow up
down the line and be like well we took
you here
i don't know i don't i didn't think
about that dr john
actually so there's partners i i gotta
i'm gonna defend her a minute okay i i'm
i don't think it's pride i think she's
uh gun shy it feels like you're you're
projecting a future
you're well i mean a future these people
will blow you up over a four-wheeler why
wouldn't they blow you up over yeah
come back later and circle around hit
you in the back of the head over a
paid-for trip
that's right yeah but i also if somebody
says man what an
idiot brother i was for losing out on
six years of relationship
hey i want to start spending some
intentional time together
and then all of a sudden i walk up and
y'all are in baby step two of this weird
cult that's happening off in nashville
and it's like hey cool come with us
we're gonna so i in the only reason i'm
asking i'm trying to be provocative with
you
how much of this is you saying i'm too
fancy
i'm too i've got too much pride to take
someone else's money
versus no man if we do this this is
gonna end poorly for us
because i think to answer your question
i think it's relatively easy
you say hey you know what we're not
going to do vacations this year we're
going to stay in
if y'all want to come visit us that'd be
awesome but we're not going to vacations
this year
next year the year after we can't wait
and then your boundaries are your
boundaries and if they want to throw a
temper tantrum over that
then you've got your question answered
for you right okay you knew they're
using this as something else
otherwise if they say great we can't
wait so we can do this again
just so you know money's never a thing
with us but we're coming
we want you with us and we're we're
going to make up for lost time then you
know hey there's something bigger at
play here
right but trust your gut right
i don't know what you think dave i guess
i don't have a i don't have a problem
either way with it
yeah john's point yeah
that uh are hovering around in his point
i i think is
um if this is truly an olive branch
don't saw it off that's what i'm feeling
and that's why i don't know how to read
well no i'm saying there's a way to
uh to you know push it to the side
gently but you don't have to saw it off
and so number one you don't need to
respond your husband does this is about
him
right and he responds and says hey bro
man
i really do want to reconnect and this
is this means a lot to me that you would
offer to pay for this and it's so kind
and generous of you
we are committed to this plan and i know
that might
not be something you understand but um
we're going to stay home
but it's not because of anything except
we're working this stuff
and i know you're paying for everything
but it's just it doesn't work for us
this year if you all want to come down
hang out get your hotel in the area
you know we'll go to dinner we'll all go
out and throw frisbees in the backyard
we'll do some stuff like that
and then maybe another year we'll go on
vacation together but
i just can't do it this year and thank
you so much for reaching out and if
if he then bows up and goes well you
won't take my gift
then you go well see there it was okay
like john john said
but it's it's a way to test the waters
without smacking
the possible reconciliation in the face
or without ending up four days into a
seven-day cruise really like
oh no what did we do no we can't get
away
yeah we're stuck on a boat now i'm stuck
in here with cousin eddie
yes yeah okay that's fair
that's fair yeah and and my husband will
talk to him i won't
respond for him uh i just we talked
about it the other day and we're like
we don't know how to save it yeah
well it's it's it's it you know it
it is way over there on the edge of
awkward
yeah but hey julie i also i also want to
put this out in the water
it is easy from you and your husband's
perspective to look at your brother
in law and say man i can't believe he
burned us for six years over a
four-wheeler
but your husband's got to own some of
that too it wasn't a four-wheeler
there's something else going on
the tools to have this conversation well
so he's gonna know i gotta be gentle i
gotta be
appreciative i wanna i wanna always go
into this thing assuming it's an olive
branch
i love that analogy dave i'm not gonna
cut it i'm not gonna saw it off i'm just
gonna move it aside
and say not this year but soon but soon
yeah gently
yeah yeah but and then that's having you
having strength and
and boundaries and you and it also gives
you a little bit of a
a little test here because i'd rather do
frisbees in the backyard than in cancun
for a week
yep you know in this weirdness so let's
just have a little
where there's a little better escape
hatch and everybody's not heavily it's
heavily committed and
you know you that kind of stuff so uh
yeah
i would want we want you to rebuild a
relationship if it's possible
absolutely and it doesn't have to start
on a paid for vacation in spite of your
hurt
and in spite of your scars yep yeah john
is in tampa florida hey john welcome to
the
ramsey show how can we help thank you
dave and john for taking my call
my wife and i are in baby step seven we
have
paid for rental property that i'm trying
to figure out what our roi is on that
to determine whether they are a good
investment to keep
long term we don't we've owned it for
about 10 years is it a
residential house uh it's short-term
rental actually
so they're vacation rentals okay um well
usually those have much higher
management fees
management company takes a big bigger
chunk right
yeah we actually manage it ourselves oh
okay um and you so you're
like running a vrbo type thing correct
okay yeah the benefit is is that you get
high rents when you get them but then
there's the off season
correct and we've had a significant
increase in property values over the
time too which has been beneficial but a
significant increase in
turnover of the tenants i mean you're
this week by week it's not
yeah okay correct it's a pain in the
butt i'm just trying to figure out
okay on residential traditional
residential
uh i i own a bunch of houses and our
portfolio averages a little north of
eight percent
cash on cash
okay meaning that the value of the
property
it we generate eight percent of the
value after expenses
without depreciation not counting
depreciation not counting
increase in value cash on cash
also the actual cash you paid for it no
the actual cash
value of the property it it's uh it
would be cash on cash if it's cash
you're correct but we do it on value we
want to see our rents coming up to match
the values to keep us around that eight
percent mark
after expenses now that's a traditional
rental house it rents for a year
not by the week by the week you should
be making more
because you got a lot more labor and you
got to account for the gap
of no rent and you got those get you
know you got these gaping holes of off
season and all that kind of stuff so
yeah you know if you're not getting
north of that you should probably rent
it straight up instead of vacation
rentage
because you got to paint you're dealing
as a pain in the butt this is the ramsay
[Music]
show
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show
did you know over 18 million people
listen to the ramsay show every week
and a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country
to find a station near you head to
thermzyshow.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the ramsey show where dad is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has
taken the place of the bmw as the status
symbol of choice i'm dave ramsey your
host
dr john deloney ramsey personality
best-selling author and
host of the ever popular dr john dalone
podcast is my co-host today as we talk
about your life
and your money it's a free call and some
say the advice is worth what you pay for
it triple eight
eight two five five two two five
triple eight eight two five five
two two five mike is with us
in columbia missouri to start this hour
hey mike what's up
hey dave first off i want to say um
listen to your show for a while and it's
changed my life
so thank you for that thank you i'm
yeah kind of facing a decision now i'm
kind of looking to make a change in my
career and i'm looking at
two jobs both of them are paying a
little better than i'm making now
but the one kind of on the lower side
um it has a better location
um i kind of it has just a lot of
intangibles
that are great about the job as far as a
good boss be a part owner in the company
but on the other hand i have another
high paying job that
the location is kind of up in the air
it's a bigger company and there's
probably more room for advancement
i just wanted to see kind of what you
thought about that as far as
what does each one pay the lower paying
job
pays about 80 000 and the higher paying
job
i could probably within two or three
years probably make double that
okay doing what in each case
um they're sort of in the sales industry
so you're so you're a sales guy
yeah sales and consultants yeah okay
so the intangibles must be pretty
stinking high for you to be willing to
take half pay
yeah um like you said it's kind of my
dream location
the the boss is a really successful guy
and
i think yeah but you're not gonna be
i don't really care about his success
i'm worried about yours
yeah unless you're 23 and you're going
to put in two years and learn from
an extraordinary mentor is going to
carry along the way and you can have
somewhere to go
yeah how old are you yeah i'm 24.
okay all right so is that your idea
you're thinking you can
kind of write you can learn from this
guy because he's a he's a butt kicker
um i think that's part of it and then
yeah the location is i want to live
there
it might be more exciting there's
something else here what's the what's
the
the thing you're not saying are you
looking for permission to not take this
job that you don't really want
he's going to pay a lot um
i don't know i guess what's the location
what's the location of the of the
underpaid one that's so
that's so appealing um it's
so i would be in training um kind of
around the columbia area
and then it's up in the air where i
would go it's been thrown out georgia
that's the eighty thousand different
locations no that's the higher page okay
what about the one that's got the great
location where's the great location in
columbia
it's no it's in the pacific northwest
black wire like seattle area
okay so you want to move to seattle
uh that's appealing to that area that's
appealing to you
yes why
i like the outdoors and you know it's
nice to be
able to kind of go in your backyard and
it's all there and go fishing after work
and different things which i know you
can do in georgia but it's just not the
same
it sounds like you're putting a lot of
pressure on yourself to make a forever
decision you're 24 years old man
and if you were telling me that hey i've
got the opportunity to work
for dave ramsey for two years learn the
ins and outs of this thing
and he's going to take me along on the
ride and
then i'm gonna have skill set uh uh i'm
gonna have to get
a ringside seat to a world class leader
and then i'm gonna have him on my
um as a reference the rest of my life
yeah dude i'll
i'm gonna be real rude for a go make the
money i'm gonna be rude for a second
okay if you're coming to work for me and
you want to move to franklin tennessee
and the reason you want to come to work
for me is because you can go fishing
i don't think i want you
well i i also like i mean it's in my
industry and it would be um
it'd be like more responsibility and it
would be more
um i would just have the freedom to do a
lot more in the company and
and you know help the company make money
you grew up in columbia
didn't you uh
yeah i've moved all over the country
doing different different things i work
for a large
contractor oh so you've already said so
okay
all right i i um
okay here's the only way i know to help
you answer the question because i'm just
confused about this
call yeah me too um the um what
a good way to do this is to john was
onto something there
it's not forever but do ask yourself the
question
what do you want to be doing when you're
34
10 years from today and where do you
want to be doing it
and what kind of money do you want to be
making and what kind of a career field
do you want to be in and all those kinds
of things
and once you identify that ask yourself
the question which of these
takes you there and the love of the
great outdoors
i'm sorry that's way down the freaking
list of the discussion on this
because if you make 160 versus 180 you
can buy an
airline ticket well especially for if
you're a salesman for the amount of time
you're going to be able to get out and
go fishing
what i'm telling you if you're my friend
if you're my son
i'm telling you at 24 years of age you
are starting to grind brother
go make your money go to a place where
you have a lot of influence you're going
to learn a lot
and georgia's a beautiful wonderful
place to live and as dave said man go
spend a few weeks in the great
northwest um but man get that
stuff under your belt and then you have
a lot more options when you're 34 and 44
and 54.
yeah but but which of these decisions
takes you to where you want to be 10
years from now
and that'll get you off the short term
of oh i don't want to live here ooh
ooh and this guy's a nice guy
none of that takes you where you want to
be 10 years from now and so the
the the decision-making variables
in this are disturbing and i can't put
my finger on exactly why i'm gonna guess
if we were to sit down and
have some coffee with this person
there's a romantic interest at one of
these places
that has a or a mom and dad interest at
one of these places well that's why i
ask if you grew up in columbia sound
like you're trying to get out of there
ah gotcha get out of the south yeah i
gotta get away yeah you know i'm getting
away from crazy family or something i
don't know i don't know what's going on
i can't put my finger
up but good luck with it dude look out
ten years and ask yourself
which of these is gonna take you there
and hopefully that'll help you answer
the question better than these two
goofballs did and she'll go with you
trust me
yeah she'll come find you if she's worth
it or you'll go back and buy an airline
ticket or whatever however that works
huh
i think we overthink stuff dave i ain't
24 years old just getting around
the mouth listen yeah you don't you know
where are you going to college
so and so why my girlfriend's going
there bad plan
warning warning this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you ever ask the question how much
should i be saving or how do i get out
of debt faster
or how do you invest because i can't
even spell it well here's the good news
you don't have to figure out the answers
on your own
ramsey plus which contains financial
peace university
will guide you every step of the way
with the ramsey plus membership you get
all the digital teaching
that you need to really understand
money so you can be confident you're
always doing the next
right thing our world-class budgeting
app every dollar our tools our guided
action steps to help you make progress
on your money goals fast
all of this causes you to win with money
many times for the first time ever
no more debt there is cash in the bank
for emergencies and
a real plan where you have a sense of
control because you have
control ramsey plus helps you get small
consistent wins every day that lead to
big results and lifelong habits to get
started today with a free
trial text trial two thirty three
seven eighty nine text trial two
three three seven eight nine dr john
dolone ramsey personality is
my co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five portland oregon is on
the line dave's calling hi dave how are
you
oh great dave how are you doing better
than i deserve what's up
i love it hey man uh good to be on with
you uh
it's funny we just started listening to
your show recently um
my wife and i up until that point we
thought hey man we got it going on and
we started listening to your show
i don't know i don't know if we have it
going on
let's lay our scenario out for dave
ramsey and see what he would say and
what he would do
any differently than what we're doing
okay you know kind of
yeah so looking for some notes i suppose
okay
yeah far away what do you got i don't
know okay i'm 49 she's 46.
uh we've got uh high school age kids i'm
a real estate broker i work
independently
self-employed she's a stay at home um
we own our home not outright that's what
we started like questioning ourselves as
we're listening to your position on real
estate mortgage you know mortgages and
debt in general
uh how much how much debt do you have
other than your home
none i have one uh we have we we own
three cars two were paid for and mine is
a lease
okay all right and so what does it take
to pay that fleece off
uh you know a 20 some odd grand worth of
lease payments probably
and what do you well give or take it
probably a little less than that but the
um
well if you're going to keep the car be
more than the lease payments but anyway
so yeah like 250 grand or something i
guess yeah so what's your household
income
about 500k cool why don't you just pay
that off
yeah you know i'll tell you where i'm
all spread around and yeah
that's one of the pots and i actually
called my account last year instead of
working at least make all of my uh lease
payments my remaining lease payments
kind of you know
tax deducted from the year b said cannot
do that um so here's what i got going
out right so i've got my house um we owe
about
870 on our house um
i have it on a 20-year mortgage start
off on a 30
and i know i don't want to have 30 years
of the mortgage payment so i refined it
to a 20 at two and a half percent
nice uh yeah yes that's about six grand
a month taxes and everything all in
um uh we own four rental properties
this is kind of also where we started
questioning ourselves like dave ramsey
said don't buy a property list if you
pay it in full
yeah um so of the four properties
one of them is paid in full uh and the
other
three are about 50 equity they're all
worth say give or take 200 grand and
what's owed on the other then we're all
less than a hundred okay well let's
start with let's start with this premise
okay
you make a boatload of money you're very
successful congratulations
very well done what what could i do
to add to the peace
in your life financially and add to the
probability
that you end up more wealthy than if you
hadn't
talked to me and my suggestion
my suggestion to do that would be let's
take this
wonderfully large shovel you have of 500
000
a year and let's line up all of your
debts your rentals your home
and that stupid fleece car and let's
just begin to eliminate debt
because if you were making 500 000 and
all of these properties were paid for
wow what a cool place
i should think so yeah and that's going
to take a while
because you got it sounds to me like you
got a million and a half or me and two
in debt
and you make 500 and so if you put 300 a
year on it it's gonna take you four
years maybe five years to clean up
everything
but the beautiful thing is that
mathematically you can do that and still
live a
very tall cotton lifestyle or you can
roll off one of those houses
that you owe and if you got one of the
rentals you're not thrilled with and use
some of that equity to accelerate the
process
but 870 on your home making 500
man you can knock that out fast there's
no panic on it the other stuff i'd be
leaning into pretty hard and
more than anything i want you to do what
you're doing with this phone call and
that's start to get very
intentional with every one of these
dollars it's easy to get sloppy when you
have this much money coming in
it's easy to get chaotic and justify
this and justify that
because you go i'll make a half a
million dollars you know what you do
that's pretty stinking incredible very
few people do
and that's wonderful so you're obviously
a bright guy because stupid people
generally don't make that kind of money
so that's an observation
yeah but and dave you taught me this
about um
scale right so i see a number like 800
000 on a mortgage a remaining mortgage
and my heart stops yeah but you gotta
lean that against half a million dollars
yeah which means nothing so you know
take that down that's 87
000 making 50. right and so when i scale
it down i remember
when i started making 30 and then i went
up to 44.
and you know what happened to me i ended
up in more debt that first year than
when i started because i stopped saying
no and you're talking about 44 000
yeah nothing compared to this but i just
thought i'd won the lottery and i quit
saying
i quit being attentive to these details
and suddenly i had owed more money than
i'm when i made less money but dave
honestly what i was hearing in your
voice was
just a little bit of as you started
listening to us she went
you know i think we're not being
intentional enough and so i'm going to
ask dave for some steps yeah
so that i can be intentional i want to i
want a path here
because i kind of been wandering around
a little bit a little loosey-goosey
little margin
in the emotions because i'm made enough
i could be sloppy and still look good
good news is you haven't made a
bankruptcy mistake you haven't you
haven't gone crazy you didn't call me up
with
uh 87 million you know right you know
her 8.7 million dollar house yeah i mean
you can call me up with any of these
things so
i i i just think you're wonderful and i
think you've got a lot of potential
i would encourage you to be very
intentional step by step
and a really good idea is let's just lay
out an
interesting little simple spreadsheet on
how fast we could pay off this stuff
if we were intentional and we limited
our lifestyle just a little bit
just a little bit because 200 000 out of
500 000
divided into 1.2 million in six years
you know and
i always want to direct people back to
the word you said dave i i've never
heard you approach somebody like that
but what you asked what you told them is
i want to know how i can add more peace
to your life
and if i can pull some of this can i if
i can pull the other end of that fulcrum
back
right if i can pull the other
teeter-totter back provide you less
leverage and more peace yeah two words
that don't go together financial peace
right you know like you know government
efficiency
yeah yeah but there's a moment when
you're making half a million dollars and
you think
i should be sleeping better than this i
think half a million times i shouldn't
feel
like i'm doing something wrong you know
or that i shouldn't be drowning as much
right yeah
that's exactly it that's exactly it and
you know uh we took a call in the last
hour
i think it might have even been the debt
free caller um
that said you know we suddenly had peace
we suddenly had a sense of control just
because we had a plan
not because we had executed the plan yet
yeah but just going from
i don't know what the crap's going on
too i know exactly where i'm going this
is going to be hard but i can do it
and this one's gone and then you get a
little and that's the time there's
but there's peace in when you can see
the light at the end of the tunnel
mathematically and it's not an oncoming
train there's some research that says
the day you make the counseling
appointment for the first time you start
feeling better oh man you wouldn't
believe the number
when we first started doing financial
counseling people would call us
up and in order to get ready for the
financial counseling meeting
they would get their crap together yes
and they would cancel
we said i talked about it oh we that's
how that's happened a lot
when you take that first crooked step
towards
a new trajectory look confused and
stumble forward but stumble
freaking forward oh there you go this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i love it in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt
free stage gabriel is here to do a
debt-free scream hey gabriel how are you
hello i'm doing wonderful how are you
today dave and dr john
better than we deserve brother where you
live i live in a little township outside
of cleveland ohio oh fun that's a bit of
a haul to nashville
yes it was a beautiful drive the whole
way down oh that's nice how much debt
have you paid off
i paid off 88 000 in student loan debt
how long did this take you this took me
34 months good for you
and your range of income during that
three years approximately
yes that would be 42 000 scaling up to
58
000. excellent what do you do for a
living i am a software engineer for a
real estate company that's also located
outside of
cleveland ohio good for you well done
dude
well done so what was the 88 you said
student loan is all student loans it's
all student loans and it was a little
bit bigger than i wanted because i did a
major change halfway through college and
that adds an extra year so
it's a little extra debt what's your
degree in computer science of course
good and then you're using it and
everything yeah
so three years ago you had what feels
like an insurmountable debt
and you're making forty two thousand
what made you look at that and say i can
do this
um definitely looking at it and saying
you got to get started somewhere
so getting hired right off the bat and
saying well this is time you know i
racked up all this debt over the four
years my degree helped me get my job so
it's time to put it to work and
pay the debt off stop it with your
accountability and responsibility man
we just can't have this yes
so what are you 29 28 close 27
27 all right good very cool he's not
only that he's a responsible millennial
that's so annoying oh
you're messing up all of my stuff all
your stereotypes are getting screwed up
here exactly right yeah
and he actually had a plan and he
executed the plan oh
lee wow i'm so proud of you man yeah
who is your biggest cheerleader uh
biggest cheerleaders i got a couple
people to reference one of the big ones
is definitely
my mother who's here with me today hey
mom my whole family came down to
represent
got friends i got an uncle and aunt that
said oh you're paying off debt let's
find some homework that we can pay you
to do got another aunt that helped me
let me know
job opening position so i could get an
extra job in the final year and really
knock out the debt so thanks to all of
them
wow wow so everybody got behind you and
gave you a lift
yes that's beautiful man there is
nothing cool about finally getting out
of college at 24
and getting your first job and then
saying
i'm gonna be in it for 36 months with no
dates no going out no running around
i'm just gonna knock this out what kept
you going every single day
um every single day definitely looking
that at some point
you're not gonna own anybody money and
it just alleviates all the pain of
finding uh money here to go do something
fun there because you're restricted by
debt and those payments that you need to
make so that liberating feeling is
definitely what
uh i looked forward to you kept looking
at that long game huh yeah
playing the long game it wasn't that
easy off the start because
uh the biggest thing that i found was
there's a difference between
dave ramsey's gazelle intense and
gabriel's gazelle
and hey listen gabe there's a difference
between dave's and everybody's but yes
you're right
yeah it started that first year making
42 and then you look down and you're
like all right i'll make double payments
on my student loans this is going to be
fantastic and then you get through and
you
get to 2019 and all of a sudden you're
like i should re-budget the whole year
and see how good i did
and i paid off 14 000 that first year
and i'm like that's not bad
listen to dave ramsey while on the
treadmill and all of a sudden i'm like
i could be doing better so i re-ran
those numbers budgeted for four things
and i actually found out
ten thousand dollars i couldn't tell you
where i spent it 2018.
wow oh and like you say you do a budget
you give yourself a raise i got a ten
thousand dollar raise
tacked it out of the 14 stretched every
dollar a little bit farther
paid off um six eight jobs yeah yeah
30 000 the next year and then i got
those extra jobs going into the third
year of
2020 and then i paid off 44 of the
remaining debt in that final year
wow that's a curve right there baby
power the snow while kicking it
you are kicking it well it was more than
snowball his intensity snowball
yeah that's that's a snow plow sacrifice
well done sir
very very well done okay so you're a
professional now
88 000 paid off you're a professional
get out of debt guy tell america how do
you get out of that
um for me what worked best i'm a numbers
guy i had spreadsheets i made my own
amortization chart so every pay day when
i sent it off to pay parent minus loans
or government loans is like
all right you know i only got 24
payments left and then 23 payments left
but having that
visualization really helps i also have
my um
debt free payment sheet here so every
time
doesn't pay them off it's just there's
the refrigerator magnet
yeah baby visualization that that's what
helped me get through it being able to
see and actually say all right we're
getting closer
it's gonna happen you know it's gazelle
intense when he didn't pull out an 80
dream journal he pulled out a single
sheet of notebook paper
and he was like done yeah six folds
hey you mentioned this guy's incredible
hitting the treadmill what are some ways
you kept yourself
sane and whole during this time that's a
long time to sprint
it is um definitely finding activities
that don't require a lot of money
are really good so anything that has to
do with a little bit of charity work
um doing mountain biking that's free
going on nature walks
uh staying home watching movies with
friends and family it's
it's being active and enjoying life just
not with the super lucrative
end of it for a short amount of time
yeah so what's the biggest thing you're
going to splurge on now that you paid
off 88 000. oh geez i could spend a
while talking about it i already got it
all budgeted out in
things but ideally i'm saving up now i
got my emergency fund so we're saving
for a home but
after we get that home i already have
everything picked out for my home
theater setup
ah this is gonna be a home theater wow
this is gonna be the real deal it's
gonna be a massive home theater
your neighbors are not going to be glad
you moved in that's good i i already
planned on sound proofing the walls so
they won't hate me that much you're
awesome
oh i'm so proud of you brother well done
very very well done well we got a copy
of rachel cruz's book for you know
yourself know your money
our latest new york times best seller
congratulations you're a hero man
you did it you took control of your life
in a in a culture where
uh the the stereotypical news feed
is that your generation is lost and
can't do anything and you proved
all of that wrong just by taking the
taking the reins of the horse and riding
it well done
i'm so proud of you thank you well well
done gabriel from cleveland ohio 88
000 paid off in 34 months making 42-58
count it down brother let's hear a debt
free scream
three two one i'm debt-free
[Applause]
[Music]
i love it wow that is
fun fun stuff
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five jason is with us
in norfolk
hi jason welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave how you doing good man what's up
well i'm calling um for a couple of
reasons
my wife and i are working on purchasing
or building a house and we've been doing
your program for now for a little while
we've paid down i think nine or ten
accounts
and we are in uh baby step number two
and uh i think it's been around forty
two thousand that we've paid
down in combined and now
the problem is this is that the land
that we're building on was heated to us
from families so
specifically to be used for that kind of
thing
and we're looking to get our houses and
stuff like that but um
we have now the only three accounts left
are our two cars
and a trailer rv trailer that i got
stuck with
with a previous marriage um not a little
too much on it than what it's worth
and so we're trying to find out what to
do and where we go and snowballing
everything
what do you owe on it doing that 27
what's it worth um
well i was told by some people 19 and
i've been told 12.
okay so you need to borrow the
difference or have the difference what's
your household income
we make about 152 right now that's good
news you can come up with a ten thousand
dollar difference and get the things
sold
yeah we're we're working on that the
question is for sale
is it up for sale um
not at the moment i have it at a
friend's house because
our current place we rent is an hoa and
i haven't been able to
get it here to prepare it to sell and i
don't have a truck anymore to tow it how
long
has it been sitting at the friend's
house
um about a year i'm calling bullcrap you
need to get your butt in the car and go
over and get that thing cleaned up and
get it up for sale man get your ten
thousand dollars scraped together but
hanging on to your old marriage brother
this thing needs to go bye-bye and if
some of these cars need to go by by and
you don't need to be building a house to
get this mess cleaned up
you need to stay in that rental house
till that happens time to get
focused dude you're playing you're
eating around the edges you need to bite
right in the middle of the apple here
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr john deloney my co-host today this is
the ramsey show
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two
five jack is in california hi jack
welcome to the ramsey show hey dave
how's it going
better than i deserve how can we help um
so i wanted some
some advice on on my current situation
um i started binge watching your show
about three weeks ago and
decided okay i'm gonna because i want to
buy a house soon so i
paid off all my credit cards um but the
problem i'm having right now is i have a
car that's
i spent way too much on last year and i
bought it brand new because
i drive about 100 mile round trip so i
spent 52
000 on my car um
and it's about 836 dollar payment
um and i was thinking okay i'm just
gonna go ahead and pay this off
um because the value has already
decreased to
like 38 000 when i looked it up on kelly
blue book
so what i wanted advice on was i have
about twenty thousand dollars in my
savings good
and i put my 401k on on hold just last
good
um because i have i had about 15
going in there um i'm 25 years old i got
40k in there
which i want to use for a house um
this year i'll make between 120 and 150.
excellent okay so and you the balance on
the car is what
the balance on the car is about 47 000
because i just bought it in september of
last year gotcha so you throw 20 at it
and that leaves us with 27
and you make 100 and some change and you
pay it off in a year right
yeah so that's what my my question was
because i was thinking of keeping
like ten thousand dollars in my savings
no you need to get rid of this car
okay you're broke man
eight hundred dollars yeah no it's
ridiculous
yeah it's horrible i'd be i'd be
freaking out
yeah and i i realized uh you know
watching your show and then i started
paying off my credit card
and i was like you know what if i if i
want to buy a house i'm going to have a
mortgage payment and an 800
car payment now you're not doing
realistic
no you're too smart to do that let me
tell you where you're struggling
okay you've learned all of this
information and implemented all of this
in a very short period of
time your intellect went way ahead
and left your emotions behind
right you know what i'm saying like you
understood this intellectually and you
went
like ding ding ding ding ding and you
start doing it
and then you're kind of like getting a
little bit of emotional whiplash because
this has all happened in a relatively
short period of time agreed
yeah and and you know what watching your
show helps me out so much because a lot
of this stuff is
stuff that my parents are very frugal um
and they taught me all this stuff and
they were freaking out when you bought
this 52 thousand dollar car
yeah but they let they let me make my
mistakes well yeah
you're a grown man and that you know
stupid's not illegal and you explained
it to them in a good way why you needed
this one too
yeah 100 miles a week which means i'm
going to destroy the value faster
that was that was me justifying it in my
head yeah but i knew i heard you did
when i was doing it
yeah i heard you but you made me realize
uh how stupid it is when i started
watching your show
i think i think you're smart and i think
you're going to turn this around
it's just the re the reason you're
saying but but
we keep the ten thousand dollars is is
not because you intellectually don't see
how this is all going to pan out
it's because you've done it all in a
very short period of time and you went
from way over here in the land of stupid
to
rushing over into the land of the wise
and you got a little whiplash doing it
emotionally it takes your emotions a
little time to catch up
so give yourself permission to go this
feels weird but i'm going to do it
anyway
and you feel exposed when you get down
to that one thousand dollars and i think
that's the point right yeah we want you
running
well and we want all that money throwing
at this stupid car to get rid of this
debt
when somebody binge watches dave they
realize oh gosh i'm not safe
and they immediately want to get safe
now yeah and so it's i get that impulse
i gotta hang on to this and let me tell
you the other thing those of you out
there that are
uh you know you've been broke for 20
years
living paycheck to paycheck and you work
through this stuff and you work your
butt off in your gazelle intense for
three years and then you're debt-free
and you don't have any payments
and then you start actually getting some
money and then you look up and you go
dead gum i have several hundred thousand
dollars and i have no debt
there's a there's another thing that
happens is your emotions are still back
there when you're broke yeah
and it feels weird to be able to buy a
ten thousand dollar thing
and just write a check for it and it's
not a big deal
yeah mathematically intellectually but
your emotions are like
back there when you were broke right so
you got to heal along the way too yeah
i mean we spend more on copier paper and
coffee here
than i used to make right in this
building i mean
okay i have a thousand employees well i
looked down at that number and i see
your heart stopped summer's going
through i'm like
i'm that little 28 year old guy that's
back there broke 30 years ago
i'm like crap yes what a coffee
you know it's like oh it's a lot of
coffee so you know
the last time i bought a new car when i
was an idiot was it was
a long time ago i went to we're looking
at buying my wife a
new car and or a used car new to her i
thought
when did the prices go up and she was
like 25 years ago right
but yeah it's that same they want what
for a used car
but as you move away from uh
one set of financial values
and operating in one financial reality
and you move into another one
your intellect often goes before your
emotions almost always
and then like it's like later on so i
have to
look down at the coffee bill and go okay
this company did bring in 350 million
dollars so we can probably cover this
coffee bill
you know so shut up you little whining
boy
yes but on the other hand i look at that
number and it just there's still that it
still activates those old emotions
and so that tells me that still today my
emotions have not caught up with
the intellectual activities required to
run a 350 million dollar company
and it may never it may every time they
do the company grows so i can't keep up
that's right that's right i can't keep
the same thing with me you know sharon
and i were looking at buying something
last night and she goes i want to get
this and
i'm going to spend a lot of money and
she told me how much it was and i went
that is not a lot of money you little
goob buy it but
that nine-year-old little girl from east
is still like well that one
the one that was terrified and didn't
think we'd ever be able to fill up her
grocery basket again in the grocery
store
yeah and now can and not think about it
but she's like that's a lot of nanny
she's like a mischievous like she's
doing something wrong i'm like honey
puts two to zeroes on it and we'll call
it a lot of money that's not a lot
i think dave that is so wise that
whether it's your marriage whether it's
your kids
whether it's your career to always just
pause
have some built-in pauses to go
here's a conversation we were having
upstairs we're working on this new book
we're uh we know we we say here if
you're not growing you're dying and i
asked the team it just hit me like a
lightning bolt
what does growing mean to you what does
growing mean to you and they were saying
you know intellectual stimulation
and exercise plan a good morning routine
and reading and spiritual growth and all
these things
and david occurred to me in this
conversation this is just yesterday by
the way so i'm still processing it but
when you go lift weights you're actually
tearing your muscles down
it's when you rest that the growth
happens and so it's both and
right it's it's crushing it and
reflection and so it's gazelle intense
and
i'm in a new stage here you are busting
the lactic acid man yeah
i'm in a new stage in a new stage in a
new stage and there's
the pruning that causes growth yeah and
man it's always a breakdown to build up
always and when you it's when you read
that hard book or that hard class it's
at night when you sleep that's when the
neurons grow
that's when the growth happens right and
so it goes back to it's both and
maybe i should sleep more i'll always
tell you that
yes but i love this gazelle
and hey don't forget to be reflective
and realize hey you're you're safe now
you're safe now and now we're gonna
start working about giving and building
and it's it's just
keep letting you make sure your head and
your heart stay connected through this
whole process man
yeah that that's um so jack all of that
rant to say
that um for everybody else out there
listening what you're going through is
normal yeah
it's a it's a normal part of the process
for your emotions to catch up with your
intellect
take the whole twenty thousand down to
one thousand work the baby steps like
you heard when you were binging
and let's get that car paid off and get
that debt out of your life and the good
news is
you can look back when you're 54 and go
you know one of the dumbest
things i ever did was back when i was
24. i bought a 50
000 car when i was 24 and you can look
back
that this could you know you may have
gotten the dumbest thing out of the way
i mean we should have gotten the dumbest
thing i was 24 check
the dumbest thing you're ever going to
do could already be on the list
that's a win that's a good way to think
and
at the end of the day you end up with a
50 000 paid off card that's not a bad
not a bad way to end the consolation
prize this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show
if you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register
we would love for you to come to
nashville and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career
you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has
taken the place of the bmw as the status
symbol of choice
dr john deloney ramsey personality
best-selling author and host of the
ever-popular podcast
by the same name dr john deloney podcast
be sure and check it out
he's here to answer your questions about
your life i'm here about your money in
your life and we've got an opinion about
everything so jump in we'll help
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five two
two five that's triple eight eight two
five
five two two five lindsay starts us off
this hour in los
angeles hi lindsay how are you i'm good
dave how are you
better than i deserve what's up in your
world
so i was involved in the classroom in
february
uh praise the lord i'm okay my baby is
okay but my car was totaled
um i got a settlement for about ten
thousand
i believe it was about ten thousand
seven hundred and i tithed on it
gave the ten percent to the lord and i
have left about
uh nine thousand five hundred and uh my
husband and i have twelve
000 about 14 000 in debt and
um i'm wondering if i use that
settlement money to pay off that debt or
do i save it
to get a new car okay so
the car you were driving the car you
were driving that was totaled
was worth how much um
i believe it was worth about ten
thousand i think they gave me what it
was worth
okay so this money is for the car that's
not for any injuries or anything like
that
yes sir sorry about that oh that's okay
i'm just saying so you were driving a
ten thousand dollar car
they gave you ten thousand dollars
approximately and
now you buy a ten thousand dollar car
right what's wrong with that plan
um well um i'm trying
it's been hard finding a car because i
commute i want to get
um a car that's reliable you were
driving a 10 000
car yes sir
before and we were not having this
discussion about reliability
okay um oh okay i guess i i
feel like you're overthinking it or
trying to try to no you're trying to use
this as an excuse to move up in car
yeah like you like you're gonna win
something you didn't win anything they
just made you whole if you if you break
even on this deal
you you come out really good or if you
move down in car you come out really
good
so what was the car you were driving
that got killed
it was a 2012 camry okay
not a bad card 2012 camera is pretty
reliable
yeah yeah it was amazing i loved it i
bought cash for it and i was really
upset
that it got um totaled so found an
amazing 2012 camry for ten thousand
dollars because that's what that one was
worth
okay all right um all right is that okay
well yeah i'm i'm i was really wanting
something that would get me better gas
mileage because i can use to work
than a camry my family yeah my camera
didn't
it did well it did okay um i just you
know not an f-150 yeah i mean
so okay what are you thinking about okay
let me just
settle this all right dude it will be a
mistake
please do not for your sake use this
horrible
tragedy as an excuse to go further up in
car
and set yourself back financially and
you are rationalizing your
butt off i can hear it so here
i'll tell you um so what i was well i
was thinking my husband just
set the record straight my husband
thinks that we should pay this money to
pay off the debt
but it's sticking out because then you
would not have a car
right exactly that's what i'm thinking
yeah so i
i want to use it for a car but i want to
finish paying off our debt
because we're really really close i want
to finish paying off our debt and then
just save like a couple
just a couple more thousand dollars to
get myself something that's got low
mileage and that will
do well like a prius lindsay think about
it this way
getting in a car wreck was not a
scratch off ticket
you did land with ten thousand dollars
in your pocket and if you were walking
to work
then maybe this is a different
conversation but you need a good car to
get you to and from
and the insurance company did what they
were supposed to do and they made you
whole
and what you're trying to do is figure
out how to make be whole plus
and you can't okay i just want you to
get back to where you were just get back
to zero that's not worse not better
that's right you didn't win anything and
the insurance did what they're supposed
to do they paid you
and so go get that same car back and
then move on with your day
and don't overthink it okay now you know
if you if you owed eighty thousand
dollars on the car or fifty thousand
dollars on the car
and this paid the car off and got you
out of a mess and we can move you down
in car
we would talk about that but your car is
very reasonable
don't move up and and set yourself back
and use some of the money you should
have been using for debt
but you're also not required to move
down to a two thousand dollar car
either in this situation so if i woke up
in your shoes
i would buy a ten thousand dollar car
they got good gas mileage
and by the way there's prius on the
market with they're for ten thousand
dollars
absolutely yeah and i'm not sure that's
moving up in car
well played i i also understand
you owe very little money left and
you've got a ten
thousand dollar check in your account
and i get that's hard
yeah but you can't you don't be careless
i mean no you can't but but i get it
and then you gotta go on and get a car
right if that was gonna work you would
have been had the car
for sale sign in the car when it got
totaled and that's that's that's where
she's not able to make that leap right
and we think that when we get an
entrance settlement we win
you didn't man that's not what that's
supposed to be no it's supposed to make
you whole believe me here
insurance settlement and win are never
in the same sense right
right that never works that way so good
question thank you for calling yeah i
love that heart
anthony's with us anthony is in los
angeles hi anthony welcome to the ramsey
show
hello gentlemen good afternoon um i was
just calling because uh
officially i was like i got out of the
main court for uh
four years talking to the phone brother
hey all we hear is muffled man you're
going to speak
into your phone yeah sorry about that um
so i was just calling uh i just recently
got out of the marine corps
um i served four years 22 years old and
i'm looking to buy my first home
with the va loan um i've been approved
for
5.5 uh with zero down
and i'm wondering how much of that would
be smart to actually
use none of it none zero there's not a
sentence that's come out so far that was
smart
except for except for the part where you
served your country thank you for doing
that that's right
but the uh uh all right so let's stop
you realize the current interest rate is
more like
two in some change not five and some
change
um yeah yeah they're trying to charge
you double young man did you hear me
yeah um it was about 3.25 yeah
about 275 okay quotes this morning
so on on a conventional with five
percent down what's the hurry to buy a
house you're 22. what do you do for a
living
um i do i t what do you make
uh 90k good for you it's awesome man
that's so cool
so you got some good training in the in
in the military then didn't you
uh yes are you married sir bachelors oh
no i'm not married
excellent okay all right my advice to
you is to wait a little while longer and
use some of your fabulous new income
to save you up a really nice juicy down
payment and get a conventional loan
the fees and the closing costs are much
lower than on the va
and uh certainly according to your quote
the interest rates are better that's a
horrible interference please do not buy
a zero down house in los angeles
california
with the way the market is out of
control right now yeah this is you're
gonna be over your head timing is
don't do this anytime you don't have the
money to do something and you do it it
never leads to good things
just think about it that way i hope we
stopped you get a great apartment
and live your life doubt i did though
but thank you for your service
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
life is full of firsts
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today
hey when folks are hurting we want to
make it as easy as possible for them to
get the guidance
get the resources they need to win to
get better
and that's why we do this every day we
want to help folks
over the past year our team has been
working hard to build a brand new
website that makes it
much easier for you to find all the
great content the tools the products the
services
that ramsay has to help you improve
every aspect of your life
not just your money and guess what it
has launched
it is called ramsey solutions.com
we invite you to check it out it is well
done
i'm so proud of our tech team all the
research and process that went into it
at your one stop shop for
everything ramsey ramsey solutions.com
all your personalities are there
including rachel ken anthony christie dr
john and of course me
all in one spot you no longer have to go
on a wild goose chase to find what you
need it's all there
easy for you to get to with a ton of
great resources
check it out it's free
ramseysolutions.com
jeff is in grand rapids hi jeff welcome
to the ramsey show
hey guys thanks for taking my call sure
what's up we got a question
yeah a question for you i've been with
the same company for over 30 years
i've invested everything within my own
company i've never ventured out to
you know independent ross and i've got a
daughter that's recently graduated from
college doing exceptionally well
where she's debt-free paid the last two
years on her own i helped her out and
she got some scholarships
she's a young 22 year old with a great
job 30 000 in the bank
wow and my question is um
i want to venture out to prepare for the
next stage of my life
and and get an elp help or
investor pro and i don't know if we
should do this together
i don't know what the best route for us
to go i know that she
i i didn't try to pressure her she's
ready to invest
so she's done everything right and i've
preached into her
which i haven't really listened to you
much i've come on to you the last few
months
from a co-worker so i'm learning myself
and i just need some guidance as to what
to do what
she should do both of us i don't know if
we should invest
i'm i'm ready to to to hook up with an
elp or a smart
investor pro is this something we should
do together or
i don't know you're independent adults
this is a father a grown lady and a
dad right yes yeah your retirement plans
are not combined in any way
with the exception when you die you may
leave yours to her but i mean other than
that
no i was just looking for an investment
yeah you can get you could both go the
same guy for investment advice that'd be
fine
so just yeah just click smart buster pro
and you know you can schedule an
appointment and go meet with a guy and
both of you meet with him and then you
can say
you what do you think you're going to
use that guy or you know do we want to
talk to another one and
you could talk that through and just
make sure you get someone with the heart
of a teacher
uh which you should that's we try not to
have any smart investor pros that don't
have the heart of a teacher
but um yeah is there it is not necessary
that you both be with the same person it
would be
okay if you are but it's not necessary
and you certainly don't have combined
accounts or combined
um anything i mean you could share
information if you want to you could
talk about what we're both doing and how
we're trying to win but
but um yeah let's let's let her
uh she's done a wonderful job of
stepping out on her own and let's let
her do that
and it's a common conversation day that
i've had with parents over the years
where they've just they've been needed
for their coaching and their wisdom and
their guidance and their direction and
suddenly they graduate college and
they're all doing well
and the parent goes what do i contribute
to them now
yeah and that's that shift where just
you're enough
just that relationship yeah the fact
that your dad she's gonna ask you
she trusts you you're a good guy but now
your your value is less about what
you're giving and just the fact that you
are
you're my dad right and that's a hard
transition for parents
it is it is yeah because we've gone from
doing everything for them
yeah and they're doing almost nothing
yeah well
and i think we were probably doing less
than we thought but we sure gave that
advice and we sure said hey
don't forget to and then you look up and
you're like i don't know i kept the
grand babies the other day they do a lot
[Laughter]
you're doing a lot for them i'm just
saying there's a lot there's a lot of
maintenance involved in them critters
oh yes there is
theresa is in boston hey teresa
welcome to the ramsay show how can we
help hi
dave and john thank you so much for
taking my call sure
um so here's our situation
um my husband and i were both 57 years
old we're
raising our granddaughter um she gets
about 500
a month for social security um we've
just been kind of
sticking it in a you know no interest
bank account um you
have told me and others in the past that
that sort of family money not just
hers um our my main question is should i
be putting that aside for
a 5-2 529 plan or should i be
rounding out my retirement um with that
extra five hundred dollars
why is she collecting that social
security um
her dad has passed away and we're
raising her i'm sorry
oh my gosh yeah what in the world
oh how long ago
um six years now and um she's 11.
okay all right well here's the thing
no you should not be putting it in your
retirement and no you shouldn't
necessarily be putting it in the 529
it's okay if you put it in the 529 but
you are not
morally or legally obligated to do that
because the ssi that you're receiving
is not enough to cover what you spend on
this child
right she cost your household more than
that
and um and so then and you are acting as
the parent
and so you're going to do what is in the
best interest of the child
well beyond what the ssi amounts to
agreed yes okay
so what is your household income so it's
about 140.
okay and then you have the 6000 coming
in from ssr so 146 correct
correct that goes at the top of your
budget 146
and then you go through your budget
regardless of where the money came from
whether you made the money your husband
made the money with an investment comes
in whether there's ssi
it's just a pile of money and now we're
going to give every one of those dollars
an assignment towards the baby steps and
it sounds like you are out of debt and
have your emergency fund and you're on
four
five and six are you um
we yes we're out of debt and haven't um
excuse me our
emergency fund you should be putting 15
of your household income into retirement
above in baby step four above that out
of your budget
that consists of all of your sources of
income
uh you would put above the 15 going into
retirement you would put
um uh uh some money into baby step five
towards this kid's college and that's
where you're going to load up that
uh 529 and if you have an 11 year old
you probably are
doing more than 500 a month into that
but it has nothing to do with the ssi
calculation it just has to do you have
an 11 year old you need to get caught up
saving for college
and that's probably you're probably
going to beef up baby step 5 and slow
down putting any extra on the mortgage
because you have a rising child heading
towards college
wide open right we also have i mean
we're 57 so
retirement's coming quick and that 500
could help
connie
there's no 500. okay there's 146.
okay so i need to put a little bit more
15 yeah of your income
household income into retirement
okay if you want to get real technical
about it i only put 15
of the 500 in just now okay
you want to be real technical about this
way the math happens to work out
but you need to be putting 15 percent of
your total household income in baby step
4
into retirement and then you need to put
all you can scrape together beyond that
into baby step 5 because this kid
you're late for college and you're
you're moving forward you got
10 more years to work this kid will be
out of college and you will have built a
pretty good nest egg by then by doing
just 15 percent
meanwhile you can work on your house
okay that makes quit parsing this money
out yeah
you didn't say uh i'm gonna put money
aside into retirement for my husband's
income and then i'm gonna put somebody
aside for my income no
we called it a household income there is
the whole
thing baby the whole thing and you don't
help your kid
by not having retirement paying for
their college and then
needing their help for your retirement
home later on yeah
your 100 chance you're going to retire
not a 100 chance they're going to
college
or to some fancy special one huh this is
true
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
from the lobby of ramsey solutions on
the debt free
stage brent and brenda are with us hey
guys how are you
hey dave good thank you welcome welcome
where do you guys live
california we're about whereabouts
sacramento oh
love sacramento awesome and originally
from new zealand i'm a kiwi
oh fun well good to have you guys how
much data have you paid off
paid off 172 thousands uh 172 750
in about 9.2 years good for you slow and
steady
and your range of income during the 9.2
uh 130 to 195.
what do you guys do for a living brennan
i work in healthcare um
yeah healthcare i'm not a nurse though i
work like a
coordinator back office type of thing
front office
so i'm a salesman i sell moldings and
doors
excellent very fun very fun so 9.2 years
was this your house
yes sir i'm weird you are officially
weird people i paid for a house in
california you are
double down on weird i love it man i'm
proud of you guys
thank you we are thrilled what is this
house worth
probably about 450 and we bought it we
bought it for about 2 30.
and you own it baby yes sir i love it
so what put you on this journey 9.2
years ago
well i've been a feu coordinator and
just
became a dave ramsey financial coach so
we've been leading fbus
and i think just
the power of compounding interest and
realizing how much money
you can bank in your own account you
know if you get ahead of the mortgage
and pay it off you can save
thousands and thousands of interest
absolutely also i'm in sales so
you know in the housing economy it can
be up and down
so it's up at the moment but one day
it's going to be down so having
having no house payment is going to be
really sweet when it goes down
yeah that's going to well i mean the
whole thing just gives you stability
yeah
yeah well done so brent and brenda the
number of
i'm gonna get in shape this year's i've
done
is a lot and i last about two and a half
weeks i work out real hard i get all the
the forms and new weights because it's
always the way it's pro how in the world
have you all kept plugging at this for
nine and a half years
we're in it together it's a team effort
and uh we both were determined we both
had like a little sign in the
refrigerator saying we're gonna pay the
house off in this amount of time and
this year and so we've been plugging
away at it
but we haven't skimped so much we've
budget everything really well
use the financial principles techniques
and also just a testimony to
the people in our class too as well
so and sometimes it seems like that date
is a far off
a little bit but once it starts getting
closer we start getting more excited
and stuff so it's like okay we're going
to pay the house off in this amount of
time
and we'll be debt-free so when you put
the number on the refrigerator
the very first time all those years ago
how far how long did it say it was going
to take you well it was
technically october 2021 so
um we just our mortgage was about i
think
about 1090 we put down 2300 a month and
just pounded it
so you beat it by about six or eight
months
over the original six or eight months
yeah very few people go longer than the
original go
yeah you almost always surprise yourself
to some degree
mm-hmm yeah and you guys did you were
the real tortoise i mean just kept
plodding man yep yes
definitely that's beautiful the
beautiful tortoise
and thanks to our coordinators out here
the three coordinators
who really inspired us and uh and helped
us as many classes have you all led
well we've only led three classes um the
last one was a virtual but
fantastic because we got to uh
coordinate with people from alaska
and minnesota just flipping awesome oh
that was via zoom
yeah that's great yeah the virtual
coordination is it's a different animal
but it's also
very cool yeah very cool very cool most
of our coordination
coordinators now are virtual so good for
you guys i'm so proud of you
all right now you're professionals you
have a paid for house in california
you're professional debt reducers
what's the secret how do people get out
of debt well
i think it's actually writing things
down i i teach my students hey
write down what is your 20 year goal and
put it somewhere put it in the bathroom
like we did put it on the refrigerator
and if you have a goal if you have it
written down you walk past it every day
and
and it just helps keep you focused and
and also teaching fbu
you know you're accountable to the other
students um but yeah
just writing it down having a goal is
important for us yeah
fabulous yeah keep it in front of you is
on anything
maybe that's the secret for the gym
thing john
appreciate you brent thanks man yeah
just just kicking me while i'm down
hey john bust feel the
john tracks so impressed you showed up
early for the show just you're my man
although for the exercise thing since
kobe they've closed so
that's kind of a little deterrent so but
you got to keep plugging away and be
creative
that sounds like an excuse you should
probably write that down and put it on
the fridge
so hey who's who is besides your
classmates who is your biggest
cheerleaders
well i i gotta tell you uh we're pretty
self-motivated
but um yeah just self-motivated i
i'm on the scale of personality you'll
appreciate that uh
john is i'm probably like at 11 as far
as disciplined
so i had to be careful to work with
brenda you know not just save save save
save but she can
spend a little money on this a little
bit of money on that okay we like to
shop
and she works in healthcare brent so
they will never find your body brothers
[Laughter]
you guys are fun that's awesome this is
so great i'm so proud of well thank you
how old are you oh uh 59 59.
okay so for women don't ever ask her
now it's too late it's too late because
i don't care
i promise i won't say she's 59.
i'm older than both of you so it's no
whining so
yeah but you're sitting here with a paid
for house
did you ever think you'd get there we
did but i
i want to share i remember at 4 35 a.m i
was in bed
i got my online payment paid the last
payment of 15 000
i remember your statement about how it
feels so different got up out of bed and
i walked across the room
and it felt like i was walking on air
and i remember that statement you made
it it was so amazing and i i told all
the classes i said hey remember those
positive moments
paying that small debt off you know
remember and embrace that because the
positive
motivation motivations more important
than the negative don't do this or don't
do that so that's true
yeah that's true there's a lightness
that is very real
oh tangible fantasy that people that
have never been there don't have yeah
i'm so proud for you guys thank you very
much what a testimony to
younger folks who are looking at a pile
of student loans and say it's going to
take me three years
and you guys have have set a marker out
there that says yep
it will and it's going to be worth it
you're just going to get up and do it
every day and do it every day and do it
every day you're going to find somebody
do it with you
and you're going to keep doing it and
then you're going to have that moment
where you float across your bedroom and
it's going to all be worth it
it was wonderful thank you thank you for
the inspiration you guys wow
we're so proud of you you're our
inspiration your heroes well done
very well done all right here it is 173
000 paid off in 9.2 years
by the way that's about seven months
early making
130 to 195 house and everything
these guys have a paid for california
house
shut up count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three two one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's so rad it changes the whole
equation for the next decade
everything everything's changed so
imagine in a year
the the real estate market is is
settling and his boss calls him in and
says hey we're gonna have to
we're gonna have to to downshift our
sales goals for doors and he'll go
all right and all right
have a good week man hope i hope you're
good
hope you're doing okay yeah yeah if you
need a hug holler at me i'm going to be
i'm going to be
hanging out with brenda i'm going to be
going on the my debt free back porch
yeah cause we don't uh have a house
payment have a good one brother
so cool guys this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day zechariah 4 10
do not despise these small beginnings
for the lord rejoices to see the work
begin francis of assisi said
start by doing what's necessary then do
what's possible and suddenly you are
doing the
impossible for the lord rejoices to see
the work begin
sometimes you cannot see the end when
you start but you need to start
anyway that's what we're saying just
start
just start you know how you become a
writer
you're right start writing i don't know
what to do an exercise program
just start do it anyway just start
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee means even if you
mismeasure or you pick the wrong color
they will remake your window blinds
for free you get free samples free
shipping and with the new promos they
run every month
you'll save even more use the promo code
ramsey to get the best
deal all right today's question comes
from ginger in california
she writes my husband refuses to deposit
his whole check in our joint account and
hides money in a separate account
he deposits only enough to cover our
expenses
then turns around and withdraws large
amounts later
he's a good father horse crap don't want
to ruin my kid's life
if we divorce that's it so
number one he's not a good father number
two
he's ruining your kids lives not you
being forced to do something about this
so there's not really a question here
dave this is more of a statement
yeah your husband is a twerp
he is not husband material he is not
father material
he is a self-centered little child
yes and he's yeah
he's doing just enough to keep his kids
fed and you
fed but he's a manipulative power hungry
idiot and then he doesn't even care
about y'all being fed later on
because he'll go get the money back yeah
so
uh what does she do from here um
sits with a counselor absolutely and
then she's
the fact that she said i don't want to
ruin my kids lives if we divorce tells
me two things number one she's thought
about it or number two the people in her
life have said you're this is over.
and so she has built this up as i'm not
going there
and so i have met with people who have
said i won't do that
and to which you say okay then this is
the
bed you're choosing to be in you're
gonna have to make the best of what you
got inside of here
i'm gonna tell her this type of
manipulation
usually comes with violence and or
volume and or other types of neglected
manipulation beyond just the money this
is a symptom
right and she's got to sit with a
counselor and begin to create a
or what plan because this is a mess yeah
and it's the uh to give you the strength
um the assurance that you're not crazy
correct
or wrong correct and the words
the narrative on how to calmly
lay down what will eventually become an
ultimatum right
or what yeah yeah and you're gonna say
you're either going to
provide for this family by putting your
whole check in the thing and we're all
going to work together
or we're going to talk about how we're
ending this marriage
because i'm not going to live like this
anymore and these kids are not going to
be raised with you as a model for what a
husband
and a father and a provider looks like
yeah because yeah
you're damaging your children by
allowing them to think he's a good
father
yes you're throwing gasoline on a legacy
forest fire yeah you're
there because they're going to duplicate
what he does times ten
yeah right yeah and to the extent he's
yelling at you then they're going to
yell and hit
yeah and to the to the extent that a
the mother of your children is simply an
annoyance and in the way of whatever
thing you need to buy whatever event you
need to attend
that's how they're going to treat
romantic partners for the rest of their
life
yeah and you're just you're painting a
model here's what that looks like
yeah my life is more important than all
of y'all's combined
my wants and toys and fun and stuff yeah
the opposite of this is we often tell
people what is the best thing you can do
for your children
love their mother well that's it when
somebody says that's the exact opposite
of this whole thing
how do i help my kid with uh screw my
kids up drinks mistreat their mother
that's exactly right hey my kids got
anxiety what i do fix your marriage
hey my kids are struggling with xyz fix
your marriage
have a great marriage start there and
then we'll start talking about the other
stuff
yeah yeah yeah i'm sorry ginger i'm
sorry it's a horrible thing it's not
even a question here it's a horrible
thing you're in but the uh
if if um you know what we're seeing
you know with what you the information
you gave us
was not throwing your husband under the
bus if it was truthful
and it is accurate and um then you are
sitting in a mess
and you need to do something about it
that's what we're saying yeah and you
probably are going to need some help
to do something about it is very few
people can navigate these things
by themselves you need someone to give
you language to it and someone to say
look what you're feeling in your heart
that this is wrong and you're being
mistreated
is correct it's accurate it's accurate
because you start to feel like you're
the problem
and you're not the problem it's almost a
domestic abuse thing and here look at
what she says i don't want to be the one
who ruins my kids lives yeah
by taking care of me and my children you
know what he has said that to her
absolutely if you leave me you'll
destroy these kids
if you don't quit yelling at me about
the money you're gonna you're gonna mess
these kids up
and she says oh my gosh i'm so sorry i'm
so sorry yeah
that it's got the same tone of a
domestic violence that's why you said
violence yeah
ryan is there ryan's in louisville
kentucky hey ryan how are you
hey gentlemen thank you so much for
taking my call i truly appreciate it
sure how can we help well um
first off i just wanted to say thanks to
your guys
program uh my wife and i we paid off a
hundred and sixty thousand dollars worth
of debt
debt-free and uh 2018.
so yeah that was awesome and um
i guess now we're sitting at uh what
would be baby step six but
we're are on active duty military
and we rent everywhere we go good and
and so i want to be saving so that when
i do retire
um you know we can pay cash for a house
so
one can i save above the fifteen percent
and two if i can
where should where should you know what
type of account should i be putting that
into
yeah your baby step six just goes in a
separate mutual fund and you nickname
that the house fund
and you pretend like you're paying off a
200 000 house and you try to get 200 000
in there okay
okay because i'm so one of the things
that i'm looking at is i'll get promoted
uh later on this year so i'm going to
get a
little over a thousand dollar uh pay
bump you know per month and so
i just don't know how much of that i
guess should i be well you should
no out of your budget your own baby
steps four five and six
you should be putting 15 percent of your
income whatever your income is
into retirement baby step four five is
kids college do you have kids going to
college
um they're all they're all taken care of
gi bill got it gi bill and then uh
and and then some are just in in the
military themselves oh okay
wonderful okay so that check that box
right
uh and so then you say all right
everything above 15
goes towards paying off the house early
only we don't have a house
so we are building a payout pay cash for
the house
fund so you basically which is the exact
same math
yeah so you throw everything in that
other mutual fund in baby step six
above 15 go of your household income
going into retirement so
in other words if you got a raise of a
hundred of a thousand dollars you're
going to raise your
retirement by 150 and that gives you
another 850 to throw towards this get
out of debt house fund
okay and i just want you to pile up cash
like
fast and furious like you were trying to
pay off a house
exactly and the average person pays off
their home in seven to eight years doing
our plan
and so seven to eight years from now i
want you to have enough in there to pay
cash for a house
okay be the same same exact math it's
just you're getting the benefit of the
money instead of the mortgage company
okay yeah it'll work for you instead of
paying that interest out that's
excellent man
yeah very well done sir and again thank
you for serving your country yeah
we really really really appreciate that
and um
yeah when you move around every two
years because they move you
and most of the housing is in a military
community where it's tough to sell a
house
you can get really stuck if you start
buying properties everywhere you go
so we tell folks if you're moving every
two years for any reason but
particularly in the military
don't buy just rent and so he was
following that advice but this gave him
a leg up on
how to offset the situation there
nothing cool to get out of the military
and writing a check for your home right
that would be pretty neat
that would be pretty neat that puts us
hour of the day ramsey showing the books
we'll be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace
and that's to walk daily with the prince
of peace christ jesus
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
you